drogenrausch ohne drogen scharfschützen
töten besser sex ist eine droge
das sind die top themen jetzt in den weg
zum top 50
sex ist eine droge die hirnaktivitäten
bei sechs wichtigen ende denen von
drogenabhängigen
das ist das ergebnis einer kleinen
studie mit insgesamt 38 probanden von
der university of cambridge dabei kam
heraus dass bei 6 süchtigen dieselben
bereiche im hirn aktiv sind wie auch bei
drogenabhängigen
um das herauszufinden wurden den
probanden pornos und sportvideos gezeigt
dabei kam sie auf ein zweites ergebnis
je jünger die testperson desto aktiver
waren die betroffenen bereiche im gehirn
das wird vor allem mit dem einfachen und
anonymen erreichen pornografischen
materials im internet begründet diese
erkenntnisse seien aber nicht
repräsentativ und auch kein beweis dass
pornografie süchtig machen sei meinen
die wissenschaftler aus chemnitz das
schwärzeste schwarz der welt entwickelt
britischen forschern ist es gelungen ein
schwarz herzustellen
das dunkler als alle vorherigen schwarz
ist dies liegt an der struktur des
materials durch kohlenstoff nanoröhrchen
die etwa 10.000 mal dünner sind als ein
menschliches haar reflektiert das
material nur 00 35 prozent des lichts
ein neuer rekord unsere augen können das
schwarz nicht wirklich sehen konturen
und formen verschwinden deshalb auch
durch das neue material und wir nehmen
nur eine scheinbare lehre war benannt
wurde die farbe mit dem namen one to
black das ein anzug aus dem material
hergestellt werden kann der in gewisser
weise unsichtbar macht steht schon fest
ich bin sehr gespannt
scharfschützen töten besser ist es
schrecklich aber leider war es wird
immer besser getötet jeder schuss ein
treffer das ist nämlich jetzt traurige
realität geworden
das amerikanische militär und die dafür
zu gewährte forschungsbehörde darpa
haben ein leitsystem entwickelt welches
dem schützen ermöglicht krumme bzw
gebogene schüsse auszuführen das ist vor
allem für scharfschützen wichtig denn
durch die steuerbare munition sind ihre
positionen schwere auswendig zu machen
zudem wird das treffen erleichtert da
umweltbedingungen wie beispielsweise
wind eine wesentlich geringere rolle
spielen flugbahn sind so stabiler und
können an bewegliche ziele angepasst
werden
wie genau dieses leitsystem allerdings
funktioniert ist nicht bekannt
satelliten ertappen umweltsünder mit
immer mehr und kleineren satelliten
sollen umweltsünder hier öl auf den
meeren entsorgen auf frischer tat
ertappt werden
es geht um ölteppiche die vom großen
tankern oder bohrinseln stammen durch
verschmutztes wasser wird jetzt mit
hilfe von kleinen satelliten schneller
ausfindig gemacht ziel ist es die
umweltverschmutzung früh zu erkennen und
die täter rasch zu identifizieren
durch lecks in tankern oder bohrinseln
kommt es zur ausweitung von öl auf den
weltmeeren zu dem reinigen manche
schiffe illegal ihre öltanks mit
meerwasser die ausweitung dieser
verseuchten flächen soll jetzt
eingedämmt werden dazu werden kleine
satelliten in den orbit geschickt über
den europäischen seegebieten
patroullieren
sie ermöglichen es den langen weg von
der entdeckung bis zur feststellung der
täter zu verkürzen
denn bislang konnten schiffe bis zu drei
stunden von den bildschirm der polizei
verschwinden viele tankstellen sie jetzt
jedoch auf die überwachung ein und gehen
so der satelliten kontrolle
deshalb sei es wichtig dass mehr
satelliten eingesetzt werden um dieser
umweltverschmutzung ein ende zu bereiten
meinen die verantwortlichen des
projektes seit beginn der überwachung
vor sechs jahren ist das öl aufkommen in
der nord und ostsee deutlich
zurückgegangen der abschreckungseffekt
sei hoch mein ulrike windhövel vom
havariekommando das von cuxhaven das
deutsche seegebiet überwacht allerdings
werfen kapitäne ihre ölpumpen jetzt
nachts an dann sind so viele schiffe
unterwegs dass die hövel mit einem
schiff mehr zugeordnet werden können
drogenrausch ohne drogen wer schon immer
wissen wollte wie sich ein drogenrausch
anfühlt ohne mal einen drogen nehmen zu
müssen
er braucht nur ein video auf youtube zu
schauen im video fokussiert ihr euch auf
buchstaben um die sich kreise und andere
formen drehen hier ein screenshot nach
etwa eineinhalb minuten ist die spirale
zu ende und wenn ihr euch euer zimmer
anschaut erlebt ihr für wenige sekunden
das gefühl einen rausch zu haben kann
sorge ist ganz harmlos
das funktioniert weil unser gehirn in
hoher frequenz psychisch stimuliert wird
wir sind also so verwirrt dass wird
bilder verschwimmen und wände wackeln
sehen da wir uns dem video dargestellten
wählen weiterhin einbilden warnung wer
unter foto sensitiver epilepsie leidet
sollte sich das video nicht anschauen
wann muss ich euch nicht vor in diesem
video aliens in unserem sonnensystem
hier klicken wenn ihr mehr darüber
wissen wollt links natürlich auch wie
immer in der video beschreibung wer
tagesaktuell informiert sein will
hier klicken für den block pixum de und
natürlich abonnieren favorisieren
diskutieren und natürlich rasieren bis
dann bleibt dran